[Music]
quite a moment at the White House say
the president struck a surprisingly
moderate tone at immigration or seemed
to while some congressional Republicans
reminded him of the stakes involved
chain migration is so insidious it is
the fundamental flaw in the immigration
policy United States any conversation
about daca is being held without that
consideration I agree with border
security as well but any conversation
about that is not going to go either
United States it Brit Hume is Fox News's
senior political analyst and for good
reason he joins us to assess today's
events hey Brett thanks yeah no let's go
some people would say senior moment
political analyst I think it looked for
a moment to well I appreciate that it it
looked today as if the President himself
had had a senior moment when Diane
Feinstein as you reported earlier said
that she was hoping that there could be
a clean bill on daca fix not as to say
the bill to let the dreamers who are
here illegally stay in the country yeah
and the president said that's what he
wanted to and the conversation proceeded
along those lines whereupon it became
clear to the Republicans sitting around
the table that that really isn't what
mister but what mr. Trump understood by
a clean bill and Kevin McCarthy the
House Majority Leader to interject said
mr. president I don't think did you
quite understand what she means by that
she means a bill that would be daca only
so no I don't mean that I mean daca with
the additional security measures which
is to say right funding for the wall an
end to chain migration and an he added
an end to the lhari system and that was
what you heard sonny perdue pick up on
and the soundbite you just played so by
the time all was said and done on this
the president had demonstrated he didn't
understand what is - all of us around
Washington a well-known term that is to
say a clean bill but he did not really
change his position on the issue so my
sense and correct me if you think I'm
wrong but the Republican voters are
watching their leaders more carefully
than they have in years past because
Republican voters in general are to the
right of Republican members on
immigration yeah I think that well I
think that's certainly true of some
Republican members and certainly a large
number of Republican voters and these
are precisely of course too
the voters who supported the President
Trump right with his hard stance on
immigration and you know in which he
suggested not only we need to stop
illegal immigrants but we need to get
control of legal immigration as well and
you know that's sort of where he came
out on this today and I might add Tucker
that what was interesting about the
response to this session today in which
the President did something you rarely
see a president to do which is to sit
there for an hour
negotiating with congressional leaders
of both parties with the cameras rolling
yeah you know you just don't see that
very often I don't think it's the kind
of thing that would square very well
with the description of President Trump
in this most recent book about which
there's been such a sensation which
portrayed him as a total ignorant dunce
with no grasp of policy who never reads
and never listens to briefings he seemed
pretty well briefed on these issues and
he spoke of them with some fluency and
in general I thought most people were
almost unbiased people looking at that
would would give him a pretty high
pretty high marks on it so do you think
it's possible that his private posture
will be different on the issues on the
specifics of border enforcement chain
migration etc than we saw today in the
public meeting well I think by the time
the public meeting was over his posture
was the same as what we've heard him say
before which is he doesn't he's willing
to do daca wants to do daca which is to
say once to keep that let the dreamers
stay here he'd like to do that but then
he's gonna insist on getting some
security measures as part of any
legislation to do that and the question
then becomes of course well how much of
the three things that he's asked for
border wall money and a chain migration
and an end of the lottery system will he
be able to get and when it gets down to
it would he would he reject a bill that
didn't have as much of what he wanted as
he's seeking and I don't think we know
the answer to that yet but the position
that at least is the position that he
staked out interesting I think voters
will be watching carefully Britt thanks
a lot for that
you bet Tucker